on l'appelle comme celle culture culture
de l'annulation ou culture de
l'effacement un phénomène qui ne date
pas d'hier mais qui connaît son heure de
gloire grâce aux réseaux sociaux 2020
aura été un grand cru pour les adeptes
de l'ostracisation organiser le concept
de caen de cette culture est large le
définir et donc compliqué en bref il
s'agit d'un procédé qui vise à comme
seul c'est à dire écartés ou bannir une
personne ou une entité pour des idées
qu'on ne partage pas ou pour un
comportement qui ne convient pas à la
doxa imposé par un groupe
prenons l'exemple de la romancière à
succès de jk rowling célèbre pour avoir
écrit la saga harry potter
l'écrivaine britannique a été la cible
d'internautes pour avoir assimilé sur
twitter les menstruations aux femmes
insupportable pour des centaines
d'internautes qui lui reproche alors
d'exclure les hommes transsexuels de son
raisonnement
la liste des victimes de cette quand
cette culture est longue et les
arguments utilisés pour la justifier
peuvent varier d'un positionnement
idéologique qualifié de douteux à
l'emploi d'un mot qui fâche en passant
par une légitimité contestée dû aux
caractéristiques ethniques d'une
personne nombreux sont les occasions
pour être consult
en juillet dernier une tribune co signée
par 150 personnalités dont le jk rowling
visait à montrer les limites d'un tel
procédé
cette atmosphère étouffante va finir par
nuire aux causes les plus vitales de
notre époque restreindre le débat que ce
soit le fait d'un gouvernement répressif
ou d'une société intolérante nuit
immanquablement à ceux qui ne détiennent
pas le pouvoir et nous rend tous moins
aptes à participer à la vie démocratique
pour vaincre de mauvaise idée il faut
les exposer argumenter et convaincre et
non pas essayer de les taire ou espérer
qu'elle disparaisse ce mode de pensée a
fleuri dans les universités américaines
notamment la célèbre evergreen connu
pour avoir poussé ce raisonnement à son
paroxysme comme le rapporte cet article
du figaro un professeur de cette
université de washington avait été
contraint de démissionner après avoir
simplement contester la tenue d'une
journée où les blancs étaient appelés à
rester chez eux pour laisser les
personnes de couleur seul sur le campus
une véritable chasse aux sorcières qui a
traversé les frontières en france la
philosophe sylviane agacinski avait été
invité à la fin de l'année 2019 pour
donner une conférence sur la pma et la
gpa à l'université bordeaux montaigne
accusé de ne pas être sur la ligne
défendue par leur organisation plusieurs
associations dont wake up
non alors au créneau et appel je cite
les étudiants à se mobiliser contre la
venue de cette conférencière au sein de
leur lieu d'étude affirmant alors mettre
tout en oeuvre afin que cette conférence
n'ait pas lieu
face à des menaces les organisateurs
avaient finalement renoncé à cette
conférence
en 2020 les comme soleure sont connus
beaucoup de victoires best seller
d'agatha christie dix petits
rebaptisé ils étaient 10 ou encore le
déboulonnage de certaines statues perçu
comme problématique
tous ces combats ne sont pas illégitimes
bien au contraire l'a mis sur le devant
de la scène médiatique de propos de
comportements immoraux peut être salué
ce phénomène permet aussi de donner la
parole à ceux qui ne l'avaient pas mais
à vouloir effacer les idées plutôt que
d'en débattre
la cancel culture porte atteinte à la
liberté d'expression une lutte contre
l'intolérance par l'intolérance en somme
surtout elle peut s'avérer
contre-productif car perçues comme trop
radicale comme le disait voltaire qui
aurait sans doute été quand celle de
sylvie vais à notre époque c'est le
propre de la censure violente
d'accréditer les opinions qu'elle
attaque